you know it's a strange time i've been
thinking a lot about
the idea of the main stream right
there's always been this
main stream reality tunnel robert anton
wilson
talked about the fact that we live in
reality tunnels and what we call the
mainstream is the sort of
widest stream it's the one most of us
live in there are other streams in the
fringes but for the most part
you could bet on the mainstream as being
the reality
tunnel that was on solid footing there
was some
kind of consensus reality some kind of
objective
truth that you could stand your ground
on but increasingly
do in no small part to social media and
its
fracturing qualities what douglas
rushkoff refers to as digifrenia
there's all these other uh streams these
reality streams not just the mainstream
that are increasingly competing
for our attention and splintering what
was once a mainstream into a series of
fringe
streams and so even the mainstream
starts to feel like a fringe
stream because all things quote unquote
being equal you can't really
tell uh what
has more weight what reality stream
carries more
objective consensus weight
you know obama actually barack obama
said that if we cannot
agree on at least a set of facts and
truths
and the whole notion of a participatory
liberal democracy falls away
everybody to a degree has always lived
in their own reality but there was some
consensus we agreed upon
red light and green light when we drive
our cars on the road otherwise everybody
smashes into each other we can't
collaborate or call
or cooperate if there's not a shared set
of frameworks but what seems to be
happening and this has been massively
exacerbated by this
pandemic is that the fringe streams and
the main
stream have all kind of collided and
fractured us to the degree that i find
myself increasingly on
strange new footing uh they they they
refer to this as ontological uncertainty
right because
ontology has to do with beingness with
reality and when
ontological uncertainty starts to emerge
it's a little
bit like alice in wonderland following
the white
rabbit the white rabbit has always been
a totem for ontological
uncertainty for the moment when baseline
reality dissolves and no new reality has
yet emerged in its pixelating wake and
i'm struggling with this because again
i am somebody that yes i i i explore and
indulge in the mythopoetic realms i'm
all about poetic truth and beauty truth
and art and all that jazz but again
i'm somebody who has always also been
grounded in at least
one dimension of reality known as
material reality
facts that you that you can't argue with
certain objective truths that are
inarguable but now
what seems to be happening is there's
the blurring
of of there is a blurring again between
the
the fringe streams and the mainstreams
and as somebody who wants to
be able to to allow oneself to to to
be open-minded enough to to to hear out
those
persuasive speakers on every um and
every side
of every opinion i find myself
increasingly convoluted because i am
i find myself persuaded by people
on all sides of a given issue and when
people on all sides of a given issue are
persuading you it becomes very difficult
to find your way and orient yourself in
the world so i feel
disoriented and i feel like we're living
in a post-truth world
and it's really problematic and this
pandemic has
has created an environment where we at
least for me i feel lost
at sea i don't really know who to
believe i feel like the agendas have
hijacked the situation and i'm not
saying
that that i fall in one camp or another
but instead i'm
i'm nauseated by the fact that all of
them are making their case and some of
them do it
quite eloquently and so you know whether
it's the
hysteria over here or the viruses of
hoax people over here
you can't quite negotiate
with these fringe stream realities and
it's really
problematic and so we really
need to come together
um and and and we need to cohere
together we need to summon coherence um
and and and yeah and disclose
once more a set of common frameworks and
objective realities that we can all
agree upon at least
so that we can cooperate and collaborate
and and move about the world with some
kind of
um orientation and so that's my
invitation during this
time and i hope that we get through this
storm and
and emerge hopefully stronger but you
know
i am concerned uh in any case i'll try
my best
to uh you know if you follow my
social media i'll try my best through my
actions to disclose my
my views so
sending love guys cheers